This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证由人类制作。欢迎收听《Look Back at it》播客。1979年对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。我是Sam J。我是Alex English。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着去理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
您正在收听的是《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games。这个空间旨在探讨黑人的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都无法安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位了解自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在AHA Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星Clayton Eckerd被指控育有一对双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg a lesbian. Michael Ranciani. My mind was blown.
艾伦女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。Greg Gillespie。Michael Ranciani。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And welcome back to the psychology of your 20s,
我是Stephanie Young。这是《Love Trapped》。Laura，斯科茨代尔警方。随着本季的继续，Laura Owens终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。欢迎回到《二十岁的心理学》，
the very unprofessional podcast, whereby I, your unqualified guide, talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s. and what they mean for our psychology. This week, we're discussing a pretty big buzzword in social psychology at the moment and over the past 10 years, FOMO, or fear of missing out. So this term, it's risen pretty steadily in popularity within the past few years, and it's become a term I'm sure we all know pretty well, and the feeling I'm sure we've all felt before as well.
这是一个非常不专业的播客，由我，你们不合格的向导，来谈论我们二十岁时的一些重大变化和过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。本周，我们正在讨论目前以及过去10年里社会心理学中一个非常热门的词汇：FOMO，即错失恐惧症。所以这个词在过去几年里人气稳步上升，我相信我们大家都非常熟悉，而且我相信我们也都有过这种感觉。
So FOMO refers to this overwhelming feeling of anxiety that an exciting or interesting event may currently be happening elsewhere, and you're not invited, non-included, it can often be aroused by, you know, your posts you see on social media or other forms of social triggers. So it's a sense that people elsewhere are having fun or doing things without you. Pretty quickly, we can see how this has links to social anxiety and has a huge intersection with psychology, despite being somewhat of a pop culture phrase in its current use. But we're going to discuss some of the psychological underpinnings of FOMO, why it's so prominent. in our 20s, possible remedies and its origins.
所以FOMO指的是一种压倒性的焦虑感，即某个令人兴奋或有趣的事件可能正在别处发生，而你没有被邀请，没有被包括在内。它通常是由你在社交媒体上看到的帖子或其他形式的社交触发因素引起的。所以这是一种感觉，即别处的人正在玩乐或做着没有你的事情。我们很快就能看出这与社交焦虑有何联系，并且尽管它在当前的使用中更像是一个流行文化短语，但它与心理学有着巨大的交叉点。但我们将讨论FOMO的一些心理学基础，为什么它在我们的二十岁时如此突出，可能的补救措施及其起源。
We're also going to discuss how FOMO has been exacerbated by social media. So why social media is so harmful for our social and emotional well-being, it's addictive properties as well, and how FOMO is part of that equation as well as being a consequence. So let's get into it. So FOMO or the fear of missing out is a feeling or a state of mild anxiety. I'm sure we've all felt at some point in our 20s, perhaps it's been stronger at times.
我们还将讨论社交媒体是如何加剧FOMO的。所以为什么社交媒体对我们的社交和情感健康如此有害，它的成瘾性，以及FOMO如何成为这个等式的一部分，同时也是一个后果。那么让我们开始吧。所以FOMO，即错失恐惧症，是一种轻微的焦虑感或状态。我相信我们二十多岁时都曾在某个时刻感受到过，有时可能更强烈。
I think in this period of life, we are often surrounded by a lot of dense and varied social groups from uni, college, to work, sports, and we have pretty large extended social circles. So it can be pretty difficult to feel comfortable in the amount you're socializing, especially with this ability to compare to others and whether people are doing things without you
我认为在人生的这个阶段，我们经常被来自大学、工作、体育等各种密集且多样的社交群体所包围，我们有相当庞大的扩展社交圈。所以，要对自己的社交量感到舒适可能会相当困难，尤其是当你能够与他人进行比较，以及担心人们是否在没有你的情况下做事情时。
or you are being excluded. Our 20s, they are such a socially fast-paced and chaotic time, and we do feel that pressure to get the most out of our younger years and have those fun bonding moments and experiences with friends that we can hopefully look back on later in life. This is entirely a natural feeling.
或者你被排斥在外。我们的二十岁是一个社交节奏极快且混乱的时期，我们确实感到压力，想要充分利用我们年轻的岁月，与朋友们拥有那些有趣的联结时刻和经历，希望我们在以后的生活中回首往事时能想起这些。这完全是一种自然的感觉。
Wanting to be included and enjoy your life and be surrounded by people that you like and feel wanted by is normal. And it's also pretty healthy. We like the company of others and we enjoy being liked as well. So that's why that feeling that you are missing out on social experiences
想要被包容、享受生活、被你喜欢的人包围并感到被需要是正常的。而且这也是相当健康的。我们喜欢他人的陪伴，我们也喜欢被喜欢。所以这就是为什么那种你错过了社交体验的感觉
can be so daunting for many and create pretty intense feelings of insecurity, anxiety, self-doubt as well. So I kind of mentioned this already, but FOMO, it's not so much a scientific term, but more of like a cultural one at the moment. However, since we have been able to label it, because these feelings have been around for many people in past generations, but with this label, we have, it has kind of become a source of research, particularly it's, you know, undeniable links to social media and its ability to confront us with all the experiences we may be missing out on.
对许多人来说可能非常令人生畏，并产生相当强烈的自卑、焦虑和自我怀疑感。所以我之前已经提到过这一点，但FOMO与其说是一个科学术语，不如说是一个文化术语。然而，既然我们已经能够给它贴上标签——因为这些感觉在过去几代人的许多人身上都存在过——但有了这个标签，它已经成为研究的来源，特别是它与社交媒体不可否认的联系，以及它让我们面对所有我们可能错过的体验的能力。
Maybe I think it's probably, I've kind of mentioned what it phomo is about, but it's probably good to define what it really means to begin. So a recent study on the subject came up with the definition that has become somewhat standard in psychological communities. So it describes FOMO as the uneasy and sometimes all-consuming feeling that you're missing out, that your peers are doing in the know-about or in possession of more or something that's better than you. So under this framing of FOMO, this study concluded that nearly three quarters of young adults have experienced the phenomena.
也许我想我已经提到了FOMO是关于什么的，但最好先定义它真正意味着什么。最近一项关于该主题的研究提出了一个在心理学界已成为某种标准的定义。它将FOMO描述为一种不安且有时令人全神贯注的感觉，即你错过了什么，你的同龄人正在做、知道或拥有比你更多或更好的东西。因此，在这种FOMO的框架下，这项研究得出结论，近四分之三的年轻人经历过这种现象。
So at least enough that they can actually recognise those nervous and anxious feelings. But I'm sure that statistic would be much higher if we also assessed people in contexts when they kept personal journals or if they were asked more frequently, maybe once a week or even once a month, whether they had had an instance of FOMO. because this feeling of social exclusion and an insecurity can be so uncomfortable. I'm sure that many others who have occasionally experienced are likely suppressing the discomfort, so probably wouldn't even realize that they have felt that unease, that they're missing out. So the fear of missing out, it's closely linked to a mild form of social anxiety
所以至少足以让他们真正识别出那些紧张和焦虑的感觉。但我相信，如果我们也评估人们在写个人日记时的背景，或者如果更频繁地询问他们（也许每周一次甚至每月一次）是否经历过FOMO，这个统计数据会高得多。因为这种被社会排斥和不安全感的感觉可能非常不舒服。我相信许多偶尔经历过这种情况的人可能正在压抑这种不适，所以甚至可能没有意识到他们感受到了那种错失的不安。所以错失恐惧症与轻微的社交焦虑密切相关，
and might be more common in those with generalized anxiety disorder, so GAD. FOMO, it's accompanied by feelings of self-consciousness, of unease, and concern about feeling socially out of place. And these all overlap with a particular form of social anxiety. A really good episode by NPR's The Hidden Brain, which is a really good podcast if you are enjoying these. But this podcast that discussed this link between FOMO and social anxiety. So in all their experiments,
并且在患有广泛性焦虑症（GAD）的人群中可能更常见。FOMO伴随着自我意识、不安以及对感到社交格格不入的担忧。这些都与某种形式的社交焦虑重叠。NPR的《The Hidden Brain》有一期非常好的节目，如果你喜欢这些节目，这是一个非常好的播客。但这个播客讨论了FOMO和社交焦虑之间的这种联系。所以在他们所有的实验中，
they found that FOMO is a function of a particular anxiety that something might happen in a group experience that will shape the group history in the future, and that means you might not be a part of that group as much as you would like to be and it will undermine your group belongingness because of something that's happened in a situation when you're not there. This can therefore contribute to a lot of fear of future situations in which you may feel judged or isolated because you didn't participate in that previous social event.
他们发现FOMO是一种特定焦虑的功能，即群体体验中可能会发生某些事情，这些事情将塑造未来的群体历史，这意味着你可能无法像你希望的那样参与到那个群体中，并且由于你在不在场时发生的事情，它会削弱你的群体归属感。因此，这可能会导致对未来情况的许多恐惧，在这些情况下，你可能会因为没有参加之前的社交活动而感到被评判或孤立。
This shows, I think, how anxiety and phomo are directly related to social vulnerability about current and future social settings in which we do crave to be included and accepted. FOMO, it's not in the DSM. So the DSM, we've talked about this before. It's the largest manual of all mental health disorders. FOMO isn't in there, but social anxiety is. And although I've mentioned how they could be linked, they are distinct, and I don't think they should be confused.
我认为这表明了焦虑和FOMO是如何直接与我们渴望被包容和接受的当前及未来社交环境的社交脆弱性相关的。FOMO不在DSM中。所以DSM，我们之前讨论过。它是所有心理健康障碍中最大的手册。FOMO不在其中，但社交焦虑在其中。虽然我已经提到它们是如何联系在一起的，但它们是不同的，我不认为它们应该被混淆。
For one, FOMO concerns fear of being excluded from a social situation. It's the fear of not being in that social situation and therefore it maybe involves a tendency towards hyper and excessive socialisation, whereas social anxiety is more commonly involves an avoidance of social situations or a fear of being in a social situation that you can't get out of. But we can kind of see how FOMO may contribute to social anxiety. So people with social anxiety, which is a diagnosable disorder, they have an intense fear of situations where they could be. watched, judged, embarrassed, or rejected by others. And the symptoms are so extreme that they interfere with the person's daily routine and prevent them from taking part in ordinary activities. In contrast, phoma was not diagnosable in a professional sense. It also concerns a fear of not being present in social situations, whereas social anxiety involves that fear that kicks in once we're
首先，FOMO关注的是害怕被排除在社交场合之外。这是害怕不在那个社交场合中，因此它可能涉及一种过度社交的倾向，而社交焦虑通常涉及对社交场合的回避，或者害怕处于无法脱身的社交场合中。但我们可以看出FOMO是如何导致社交焦虑的。所以患有社交焦虑症（这是一种可诊断的疾病）的人，对他们可能被他人注视、评判、尴尬或拒绝的情况有强烈的恐惧。症状非常极端，以至于干扰了人的日常生活，并阻止他们参加正常的活动。相比之下，FOMO在专业意义上是不可诊断的。它也关注害怕不在社交场合中，而社交焦虑涉及一旦我们
in them. So there are some tenuous links between social anxiety and this fear of missing out. They're both, you know, directly related to relationships and the social element of our psychology. But FOMA seems to be its own class of anxiety and our knees. It's important to know why it occurs from a psychological perspective before we can grasp onto how to minimize it. So let's dive into the possible causes and what the literature says about this universal fear of missing out. Firstly, many theories have hypothesized that FOMO emerges from a pre-existing insecurity or unhappiness. Those who are experiencing low levels of satisfaction around fundamental needs for competence, autonomy, and relatedness, they tend towards higher levels of fear of missing out,
身处其中时就会触发的恐惧。所以社交焦虑和这种错失恐惧症之间存在一些微弱的联系。它们都直接与人际关系和我们心理的社交元素相关。但FOMO似乎是属于它自己的一类焦虑和不安。在我们掌握如何将其最小化之前，从心理学角度了解它为何发生是很重要的。那么让我们深入探讨可能的成因，以及文献对这种普遍的错失恐惧症的说法。首先，许多理论假设FOMO源于预先存在的不安全感或不快乐。那些在能力、自主性和相关性等基本需求方面满意度较低的人，往往会有更高水平的错失恐惧症，
as to those who have lower levels of just general mood and overall life satisfaction. It does appear that the root of FOMO is not so much about any. anxiety, but it's more to do with loneliness, low self-esteem, low self-compassion. If you're more satisfied with your life, not just your social relationships, researchers have found that you're less likely to have experiences of FOMO, even if you are confronted by the idea that you are potentially missing out on an experience or something you'd like to be included in. In that way, the kind of interpretation I have of that is that emotions associated with FOMO,
那些总体情绪和生活满意度较低的人也是如此。FOMO的根源似乎与其说是任何焦虑，不如说是与孤独、低自尊、低自我同情有关。如果你对自己的生活更满意，而不仅仅是社交关系，研究人员发现你经历FOMO的可能性就越小，即使你面临着你可能错过了某种体验或你想参与其中的事情的想法。从这个意义上说，我对它的解读是，与FOMO相关的情绪，
they're more of a proxy for deeper dissatisfaction with one's life. And the experience of the experience of missing out may also just serve to reinforce previous negative emotions and self-perceptions, hence why it can be so overwhelmingly and overall a distressing experience. Another interesting study I looked into, it discussed how humans appreciate gains versus losses as an explanation for FOMO. So research suggests that people are twice as affected by loss. as they are gains. So it makes sense that our instinct is to avoid the pain of missing out
它们更多是对生活深层不满的代理。而错失的体验也可能只是起到强化先前负面情绪和自我认知的作用，这就是为什么它总体上可能是一种压倒性的、令人痛苦的体验。我研究的另一项有趣的研究讨论了人类如何欣赏收益与损失，以此作为FOMO的解释。研究表明，人们受损失的影响是收益的两倍。所以我们的本能是避免错失的痛苦，
and dwell on those defeats when we do. And it also suggests why this feeling can be stronger than the actual gains we get when we are socialising or we are included. This also ties into a more traditional evolutionary perspective that kind of explains why we do feel a loss when we aren't enjoying the company of those we'd like to be around. Essentially, we're pack animals. And in the past our survival was intimately linked to being surrounded by others of our species. That's why that discomfort we feel with FOMO, it may have actually originated from this deep root of fear of danger or threat, and that we might be less equipped to deal with those threats when we're alone or not in a group. So if our natural tendency is towards being around others
并在我们错失时沉溺于那些失败中，这是有道理的。这也表明了为什么这种感觉可能比我们在社交或被包容时获得的实际收益更强烈。这也与一种更传统的进化视角联系在一起，这种视角解释了为什么当我们没有享受我们想与之在一起的人的陪伴时，我们会感到一种损失。本质上，我们是群居动物。在过去，我们的生存与被同类包围密切相关。这就是为什么我们对FOMO感到的那种不适，可能实际上起源于这种对危险或威胁的恐惧的深层根源，以及当我们独自一人或不在群体中时，我们可能不太具备应对这些威胁的能力。所以如果我们的自然倾向是与他人在一起，
is towards being included and being in a community, because of that survival mechanism, it does explain why missing out can be such a tremendous stress for some. So if our brains are hardwired towards social interaction and a sense of belonging, and we receive a benefit or a gain from socialising, which in turn creates the idea of loss when we aren't socialising, that just creates the foundation for FOMO. It's not really your fault, it's genetics, it's biology. It's that instinct in you to want to be included and want to be accepted.
是倾向于被包容并处于一个社区中，因为这种生存机制，这确实解释了为什么错失对某些人来说可能是一种巨大的压力。所以如果我们的大脑天生倾向于社交互动和归属感，并且我们从社交中获得利益或收益，这反过来又在不社交时产生了损失的概念，这就为FOMO奠定了基础。这真的不是你的错，这是遗传，这是生物学。这是你内心想要被包容和被接受的本能。
But let's kind of introduce the next, evil that is particularly dominant amongst those in their 20s, social media. Social media has been a large focus among psychologists who've been investigating FOMO for many obvious reasons. The rapid growth of social media over the last decade has established an entirely new medium for human interaction. So, you know, Twitter, Facebook, Instagram, they've allowed people in every corner of the world to be connected 24-7. And it's a lot. also allows people to share, you know, the best and greatest moments of their life with essentially everyone they know for public viewing.
但让我们介绍一下下一个在二十多岁的人群中特别占主导地位的恶魔：社交媒体。社交媒体一直是心理学家调查FOMO的一个重点，原因显而易见。过去十年社交媒体的快速增长为人类互动建立了一个全新的媒介。所以，你知道，Twitter、Facebook、Instagram，它们让世界各个角落的人们能够24-7保持联系。而且它也
Okay, I don't think it's just me, you know, seen an Instagram story of people hanging out and you felt a sense of FOMO, despite, you know, you might be busy yourself or being around, you might be around others whose company you actually really enjoy. But if you're already not feeling like so hot about things, or if you're wondering if everyone else is having more fun than you. Social media is not really the antidote. So researchers are finding that the fear of missing out is connected to social media use. These feelings strongly correlate to feelings of regret and social insignificance as well. As people consume large amounts of social media posts, they start to compare themselves
允许人们与他们认识的基本上所有人分享他们生活中最好、最伟大的时刻，供公众观看。好吧，我不认为只有我一个人看到人们聚在一起的Instagram故事时感到FOMO，尽管你可能自己很忙，或者你可能被你真正喜欢其陪伴的其他人包围着。但如果你本来就对事情感觉不太好，或者如果你在想别人是否比你玩得更开心。社交媒体并不是真正的解药。所以研究人员发现，错失恐惧症与社交媒体的使用有关。这些感觉与后悔和社交无意义感强烈相关。当人们消费大量的社交媒体帖子时，他们开始比较自己，
not only physically as we would traditionally think, but also socially. researcher who does a lot of work on this, his name's Dr. Barry. And he talks a lot about FOMO and internet use, and he explains the link between the two pretty excellently. So we're not all equally prone to the fear of missing out, but for those who are social media can exacerbate it. So if we're thinking about some of those discussions of the origins of social media or the origins of FOMO, if you're already feeling insecure or insignificant social media is kind of like the fuel on the pre-existing fire. And it's because it allows you to kind of observe what other people are doing
不仅是在身体上（正如我们传统上认为的那样），而且是在社交上。一位在这方面做了大量工作的研究员，他的名字叫Barry博士。他谈了很多关于FOMO和互联网使用的问题，他非常出色地解释了两者之间的联系。所以我们并非都同样容易产生错失恐惧症，但对于那些容易产生的人来说，社交媒体会加剧它。所以如果我们思考一些关于社交媒体起源或FOMO起源的讨论，如果你已经感到不安全或无意义，社交媒体就像是预先存在的火上的燃料。这是因为它让你能够观察别人在做什么，
and what's going on in their lives at any time of the day. So if there is already that concern about missing out, then there will be distress at seeing that on social media because it reconfirms fears and insecurities that were pre-existing. So social media kind of acts like a trigger. So that's the first direction of the relationship between, social media and this fear of missing out whereby social media like I said acts as a trigger but fear of missing out can exist independently of social media and it can alternatively kind of act as
以及他们一天中任何时候的生活中发生了什么。所以如果已经存在对错失的担忧，那么在社交媒体上看到这一点就会产生痛苦，因为它重新确认了预先存在的不安全感和恐惧。所以社交媒体就像一个触发器。这就是社交媒体与这种错失恐惧症之间关系的第一方向，即正如我所说，社交媒体充当了触发器，但错失恐惧症可以独立于社交媒体存在，它可以交替地充当
that primary urge to check social media so it creates a self-fueling cycle it doesn't just work in one direction so in one study phomo amongst young adults between 19 and 24 was robustly associated with social media engagement and a similar study run in parallel, so I think they were like sister studies. It found that fear of missing out played a key role in explaining social media engagement over and above any other factor that was considered. So those high in FOMO, they tended to use Facebook more often immediately after waking up before going to sleep, during meals, at work, in the bathroom, all of those kind of habits that create a dependency on social media and make it more of a lifestyle rather
那种检查社交媒体的主要冲动，所以它创造了一个自我燃料循环，它不仅仅是在一个方向上起作用。因此，在一项研究中，19至24岁年轻人中的FOMO与社交媒体参与度密切相关，而一项并行进行的研究（我认为它们是姐妹研究）发现，错失恐惧症在解释社交媒体参与度方面起到了关键作用，超过了考虑的任何其他因素。所以那些FOMO程度高的人，往往在醒来后、睡觉前、用餐时、工作时、在洗手间里更频繁地使用Facebook，所有那些创造对社交媒体依赖并使其更像是一种生活方式的习惯，
than just something that is an addition to your life. So essentially, preliminary feelings of missing out, it leads people to check social media more frequently as it can be comforting, because if you don't see people hanging out, it kind of disproves those internal feelings. However, when you do see an image or a post that indicate that you're not being included, it can only serve to hurt you more,
而不是仅仅作为你生活的一个补充。所以本质上，初步的错失感导致人们更频繁地检查社交媒体，因为这可能令人安慰，因为如果你没有看到人们聚在一起，它在某种程度上反驳了那些内在的感觉。然而，当你确实看到一张图片或帖子表明你没有被包括在内时，它只会让你更受伤，
but it also reconfirmed that fear you are having, you weren't crazy, that it was legitimate, which can also be comforting in itself. And we all know that social media, it's not a balanced picture of people's lives. It is a cherry-picked, edited, perfect version. And even if we recognize that in ourselves, that we put filters on our photos, we only choose the best images. We only post when we're out with people and having fun. You know, we're selective.
但它也重新确认了你正在经历的那种恐惧，你并没有疯，它是合法的，这本身也可能令人安慰。我们都知道社交媒体并不是人们生活的平衡写照。它是一个精挑细选、编辑过的、完美的版本。即使我们在自己身上认识到这一点，我们给照片加滤镜，我们只选择最好的图像。我们只在我们和别人出去玩的时候发帖。你知道，我们是有选择性的。
It's hard to apply that logic evenly to others. We really just can't help but compare, especially from a point of social comparison as well. So people who use social media more frequently have a higher probability of comparing their achievements and their bodies and their social lives with those of others. And that passive consumption of social media content also correlates to a marginal increase in depression and unhappiness as well, which we already know actually does predispose someone to a fear of missing out. So it all becomes more and more related, the more you look into the direction of the relationship between a fear of missing out and social media. So even if we logically know that what we see on Facebook or Instagram isn't accurate, we're still confronted with a perfectly curated version of others' lives.
很难将这种逻辑均匀地应用到别人身上。我们真的忍不住要比较，特别是从社会比较的角度来看。所以更频繁使用社交媒体的人，比较他们的成就、身体和社交生活与他人成就、身体和社交生活的可能性更高。而这种对社交媒体内容的被动消费也与抑郁和不快乐的边际增加相关，我们已经知道这确实会使人容易产生错失恐惧症。所以当你深入研究错失恐惧症和社交媒体之间关系的各个方向时，一切都变得越来越相关。所以即使我们在逻辑上知道我们在Facebook或Instagram上看到的内容并不准确，我们仍然面对着他人生活的一个完美策划版本。
And it does create an unachievable false social reality that can exacerbate an already vulnerable self-esteem. you just can't compete with someone's highly edited depiction of their life, especially when you're feeling a little bit down or anxious to begin with. So how do we overcome FOMO? How do we overcome this sense that we're missing out, this sense of insidious kind of social anxiety? Because it can feel, like I said, quite insidious, especially in socially claustrophobic environments
它确实创造了一个无法实现的虚假社交现实，可能会加剧已经脆弱的自尊心。你只是无法与别人高度编辑的生活描述竞争，特别是当你本来就感到有点沮丧或焦虑时。那么我们如何克服FOMO呢？我们如何克服这种错失感，这种阴险的社交焦虑感？因为它可能感觉，正如我所说，相当阴险，特别是在社交幽闭恐惧的环境中，
that sometimes dominate our 20s, like graduate programs, uni, colleges, sports teams. teams, we can see the evident links to social media usage firstly. And it's origins in a more general sense of inadequacy and unhappiness, as well as the explanation that FOMO is also a variant of social anxiety. So with that in mind, maybe an intentional model is the best antidote or provides the best insight into a cure, even though it's not a diagnosable illness. Yeah, just something to soothe those kind of worries.
这些环境有时主导了我们的二十岁，比如研究生项目、大学、学院、运动队。我们首先可以看到与社交媒体使用的明显联系。以及它在更普遍的不适感和不快乐感中的起源，以及FOMO也是社交焦虑的一种变体的解释。考虑到这一点，也许一个注意力模型是最好的解药，或者提供了对治愈方法的最佳洞察，即使它不是一种可诊断的疾病。是的，只是为了缓解那些担忧。
So most attentional models of mental well-being, and I love an attentional model of mental well-being, I think they're kind of spot on. But they often put forward the theory that our happiness, it's directly caused by how we allocate our attention. So one researcher puts it perfectly in an article. They wrote about FOMO in your 20s. When you attend, what you attend to drives your behavior and it determines your happiness. Attention is the glue that holds your life together. The scarcity of attentional resources means that you must consider how you can make and facilitate better decisions about what you pay attention to and in what ways.
所以大多数心理健康的注意力模型，我喜欢心理健康的注意力模型，我认为它们相当准确。但它们经常提出这样一个理论：我们的幸福直接取决于我们如何分配我们的注意力。所以一位研究人员在一篇文章中完美地表达了这一点。他们写了关于你二十岁时的FOMO。当你关注什么，你关注的东西驱动你的行为，它决定了你的幸福。注意力是维系你生活的胶水。注意力资源的稀缺意味着你必须考虑如何做出并促进关于你关注什么以及以何种方式关注的更好的决定。
If you're not as happy as you could be, then you must be misallocating your attention. So changing behaviour and enhancing happiness is as much about withdrawing attention from the negative as it is about attending to the positive. So that might seem quite broad and it can be applied to many other facets. of our lives in our early 20s. But let's think about it in the context of this anxiety or fear of missing out. Firstly, the more time you spend consuming social media, the more of your attention is devoted to this cherry-picked highlight reel of others' lives.
如果你没有你可能达到的那么快乐，那么你一定是在错误地分配你的注意力。所以改变行为和增强幸福感，既在于从负面事物中撤回注意力，也在于关注正面事物。但这看起来可能相当广泛，它可以应用于我们二十出头时生活的许多其他方面。但让我们在焦虑或错失恐惧症的背景下思考它。首先，你花在消费社交媒体上的时间越多，你投入到他人生活这个精挑细选的精彩片段上的注意力就越多。
And this will control how you formulate your own vision of your life, especially your social life. And it can cause you to set up unrealistic expectations about what others are doing. and how your own interactions should compare. So focus on being present in the experience you're in rather than what you might be missing out on. And since social media is the most prominent point of comparison, limiting its use is actually probably pretty useful
这将控制你如何制定自己的人生愿景，特别是你的社交生活。它会导致你对别人在做什么以及你自己的互动应该如何比较设定不切实际的期望。所以专注于活在你所处的体验中，而不是你可能错失的东西。由于社交媒体是最突出的比较点，限制其使用实际上可能相当有用，
for also minimizing feelings of FOMO. Secondly, place greater attention and focus on the moments when you do feel present, when you do feel included and you're happy and who you're around, in those situations where you have those positive feelings. Who really brings that out in you? This will create greater satisfaction in general, and it does also allow you to be less concerned
对于最小化FOMO的感觉也是如此。其次，将更多的注意力和焦点放在你确实感到在场、感到被包容、感到快乐以及你周围的人身上，在那些你有这些积极感觉的情况下。谁真正激发了你内心的这些感觉？这将创造更大的总体满意度，它也确实让你不那么担心
about what others might be doing without you if you're surrounded by people whose company you really value. But obviously, just a big disclaimer, I'm not a professional. I'm just an amateur kind of applying my own interpretation of some of these psychological theories, but I think this fear of missing out is universal amongst 20-something-year-olds, which is kind of ironic, you know, considering we're all feeling the same way about the
如果你被你真正重视其陪伴的人包围，别人在没有你的情况下可能在做什么。但显然，只是一个大免责声明，我不是专业人士。我只是一个业余爱好者，应用我自己对其中一些心理学理论的解读，但我认为这种错失恐惧症在二十多岁的人群中是普遍存在的，这有点讽刺，你知道，考虑到我们都在为
situations we're in and we're currently envious of someone else who might be envious of us. So maybe that's where the greatest piece kind of comes from. If you are around people you enjoy and you're grateful for, it will become harder for those feelings of missing out to come up. And if you realize that others also have those feelings, kind of puts things in perspective that no one is having any more fun than anyone else. Anyhow, finishing that up on a bit of a sappy note there, hope you've learnt something and could relate to some of the experiences that we've discussed
我们所处的环境感到同样的感受，并且我们目前羡慕别人，而别人可能也在羡慕我们。所以也许这就是最大的平静来源。如果你周围的人是你喜欢的并且你心存感激的，那么那些错失的感觉就更难出现。如果你意识到别人也有这些感觉，这会让你从某种角度看待问题，即没有人比任何人玩得更开心。总之，以一点感伤的语气结束，希望你学到了一些东西，并且能够与我们讨论的一些经历产生共鸣，
in this slightly shorter episode. It was actually super fun to look into this, especially having experienced this quite often in my first year of uni. So it's nice actually to look back and realize I'm not in that place anymore. and those feelings of phoma for me have kind of lessened since I've gotten such better friends and valued my social interactions by their quality rather than their quantity. But thanks for tuning in. Next week we have a lovely, lovely guest on the show for our second Let's Get Friendly episode.
在这一集稍微短一点的节目中。实际上深入研究这个问题超级有趣，特别是在我大一的时候经常经历这种情况。所以回首往事并意识到我不再处于那个位置，这真的很好。而且自从我交到了更好的朋友，并按质量而不是数量来衡量我的社交互动以来，我那种FOMO的感觉已经减轻了。但感谢收听。下周我们将有一位可爱、可爱的嘉宾来到节目中，参加我们的第二集《Let's Get Friendly》。
And after that, we're going to be talking about the psychological concept of flow, which is one I'm really, really looking forward to. So I'm excited. I hope you guys are as well. Remember to subscribe to us on Spotify or Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcast. Give us a follow on Instagram and, yeah, stay tuned for future episodes. Thanks again for listening in and I hope you have an incredible week. Bye.
在那之后，我们将讨论心理学概念“心流”，这是我非常、非常期待的一个概念。所以我很兴奋。我希望你们也是。记得在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上订阅我们，无论你在哪里获取播客。在Instagram上关注我们，是的，敬请期待未来的剧集。再次感谢收听，希望你有一个不可思议的一周。再见。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it. with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
欢迎收听《Look Back at it》播客。1979年对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。我是Sam J。我是Alex English。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈论80年代。
It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
那真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？您正在收听的是《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kier Games。这个空间旨在探讨黑人的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都无法安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位了解自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct?
有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在AHA Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星Clayton Eckerd被指控育有一对双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。艾伦女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。Greg Gillespie和Michael Ranjini。我惊呆了。我是Stephanie Young。这是《Love Trapped》。Laura，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着本季的继续，Laura Owens终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个I-Heart播客。保证由人类制作。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。